hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba love job
cuz you always do this to loans yeah we
just obviously came out of Rambo last
blood huh a man do I hope this is Lewis
now I gotta keep going till they nail it
before we go into this review I didn't
read any capsules but I saw the
consensus and I saw I was like 30% on
critics and I saw I was like 80s yeah
somewhere on the audience score okay
audiences seem to be liking this okay
and if you're part of that crowd that
really likes this and doesn't want to
hear an opinion that does not support
that keep watching this yeah you're
gonna get exactly what you want the end
he's a cowboy now he's just raising
horses on a farm and hanging out in
tunnels making weapons he's got a nice
is nice wants to go to Mexico where I
said well illogical fathers there's
wants to confront her dad then she gets
put in sex trafficking
Rambo wants to rescue her who's more to
begin Stallone he's good he's good in
this missile owns good it's weird
because obviously without even diving
into details yet clearly don't like this
movie but Stallone does do a good like
there are moments we're still on us to
get pretty big with his emotion and he
was very believable
also give it that there were violent
moments that I had fun with there are
moments where when it's violent and
that's when it's really entertaining
yeah I guess the one thing that this
movie arguably does that you know you
want from a Rambo movie that you get
from this Rambo movie yeah yeah yeah
that being said there were a few times I
just wanted to leave TV yeah I feel like
Stallone really showed up for the acting
side of his yet with this movie and not
the other side's namely the script the
script of this is not good and it's not
this isn't one of the it's weird because
it's not one of those movies that it's
exciting to get
camera and talk about I was so bad I
want to rip this movie a new one or it's
so bad that it's fun and cheesy and yeah
yeah cuz I by the time it was done I was
just like empty and hollow I just I I
don't feel good the word that kept
coming to mind for me when watching this
was this feels very pretentious
it feels like it's this meaningful
character film it's supposed to wrap up
the legacy of some kind
commenting on issues in today's world if
I comment do you mean it's telling you
that sex traffickers are perfect bad
yeah then yes and it's it's insanely
melodramatic oh yeah and they it really
feels like there's a this really obvious
finale that if you've seen one trailer
you know where this movie is going yeah
that there's this finale that they're
setting up for and it seemed like they
thought of a cool fun I don't know if
this is the process it just kind of felt
like this when I when I watched it that
they had a cool finale in mind and
they're like alright so what's like the
most thin then they written develop
stuff we can do just to make everyone it
seems so horrible the way this movie's
written with so many of the scenes
characters will just talk about each
other's backgrounds and past specific
time so clearly whatever was in the
outline practice and exactly what
they're feeling is and what the point of
their dialogue is you know this is
weirdly hardcore bleak world everyone's
pretty good with their communication I
was like did you just read the outline
and go improv based on that I was like
you're gonna hide this in dialogue okay
the facts you asked about the history of
the characters if you haven't seen the
movie and you hear people say something
like that it can sound like you know
it's not about that it's about the fun
violence and the thing is the violence
in this movie the finale violence has
this sense of like weird like oh and now
it seems to having fun with it so
ergonomical badass and yours watch and
slide take fools down but the most of
the movie the tone the world even the
violence before the finale so bleak and
so nasty it's ugly and there's nothing
almost
about anything it's a very mean-spirited
movie in a lot of ways especially with
the way they treat Rambo's nice in this
movie there were things that happened
but with that character I was like movie
eight or so much this person do to
deserve so much tears like if this was
like a Sicario type movie this could
maybe fly because there are certain
choices that this movie makes that
almost feel unique except for its in
this particular movie so they just add
to the ugliness of everything and and
I'm a viewer who does appreciate you
brought up that Rob Zombie example and
yeah there are times when I appreciate
ugliness in the right format or in the
right context but for what this movie is
trying to do and I think the response it
wants it doesn't even strike that line
no it feels false it feels forced
that's why I said pretentious because it
feels like they're trying to manipulate
you so that way you'll get to a point in
the finale where you're like yeah kill
him Rambo for me a by the time they got
to the finale
I was already sold myself on how much I
don't like being in the theater so I
could I couldn't even I couldn't fully
enjoy it was I entertained during it
yeah
weirdly simultaneously I was also like
kind of mad at the movie I mean the
third act is arguably the best part of
the movie it flows the best it's the
least interrupted any other nonsense
yeah or any other things that should be
so much better it's all physical so it
works but yeah the issue is like the
first act is so like ain't nothing bad
gonna happen to beg telegraphing and the
second act goes a place that you like
their outcomes you might not expect but
then it gets just ugly and boring and
then at the end it pops off and yeah
like the kills are cool you hate these
people because they're sex traffickers
so like by default they're easy to hate
but yeah the movie does kind of just
manipulate every response it gets out of
you and I guess I was mad because I just
didn't feel like it
earned fun no over-the-top kills they
you know like no not after how nasty and
thin everything's yeah you know it's
like it doesn't totally mesh well at all
firm it didn't match
yeah it's like the thing that should
drive the satisfaction it's like it's
still yes these characters are
despicable they arguably yeah could die
but at the same time the movie doesn't
have isn't enough to feel good about
after that it's just a dead and
manipulative factor yeah it mostly plays
on your rage you know yours like yeah
kill people who do its obscenely
terrible stuff but it's not a real beat
the movie er no no no everything just
seemed like ingredients but not a fully
cooked recipe
kind of a weird criticism I couldn't
tell if this movie was racist I just
it's not helping I couldn't
it was a strange isn't like well it's
just the characters and there are some
things that happen in this movie I'm
like is this Stallone commenting on this
there are some Stallone films that are
written beautifully and then there are
some Stallone scripts like this one that
are just incredibly on the nose with
like every character doesn't talk like a
real one by this movie's logic traveling
from Arizona and Mexico is easy alright
traveling back and forth the whole movie
when I was like looking at this movie I
really hit me that there's there's only
one good male character in this movie
and that's Rambo and nearly two other
good characters are the woman he's
living with and yes large Mexican yeah
yeah which is cool it's just when when
he when he hears that she's going to
Mexico she says to him I want to go to
Mexico and he says do I do that I mean
that's before we hear about the father
thing maybe maybe he's in ten maybe he
was assuming that's my reaction why
don't you want to go to Mexico every
element of Mexico in this is just so
ugly off-putting there's a few connexin
characters like good heart and mexican
characters there's like there are three
women I could think of yes maybe but all
the dudes are bad yeah it's because
they're focusing on the sex trafficking
gangster [ __ ] me so that makes sense
and that's why I'm saying we don't need
nothing good about Mexico even like the
strangers who she's encountering who are
not actual characters just seem to gawk
at seem like they're like really else
you soon yeah everything looks dangerous
and shifty and yeah yeah it's one of
those things where you go well it's neat
that there are so many
Latino actors in this movie but yeah
there are mostly relegated to the types
of roles that are not helping
I imagine the Latino community at large
in the acting sphere and in any sphere
really it's weird to watch him really I
can't tell if the Latino view will be a
fan or not I can't I can't even is this
a battle or is this not a battle for if
you like it is like percolating under
the surface in a way that's just
unidentifiable enough that you can't
decide right before filming I decided
look up who this director was he
directed a movie that I find very
underrated that's also about a white guy
being surrounded by not-so-good Mexicans
but it's actually a great film and it's
it's have you seen it get the gringo
it's a really good movie it has a
hurry-up life star who's a lot more
problematic this is what fun about life
is that these nuances expensive but
there's completely different tones and
styles and a completely different story
overall it surprised me to learn that
because I watched this movie feeling
like was this this directors first movie
really and then you I watch you get the
green which seems like a much bigger
film actually yeah I'm just shocked of
how poorly paced and edited and just
overall executed this movie is there's
so many random shots that are cut in
that almost seemed to not follow like
there's so many weird inserts that don't
translate in the don't segue properly
there's even like plot points in there
like with Rambo is PTSD and medication
that just kind of goes out the window
and yeah he throws the bottle down like
maybe those meds were keeping him down I
don't want his hand on the script even
and I didn't even feel like that like I
wonder on every I think except the first
Rambo I think his hands went on like
yeah I don't know what he did other than
maybe take a pre-existing script and
changed the names to Rambo but like it
doesn't feel like it has his panache for
character yeah and for a movie called
last blood it feels like and significant
yeah it doesn't feel definitive or
important it just feels like another
adventure Rambo could have gone on which
is a bummer when you're not only coming
to arguably in a
franchise but you've also got Stallone
back at like in the Twilight even the
older years of his life like this is an
opportunity and I feel like it wouldn't
have been that hard to make this into
something at least a bit more
substantial and a bit better yeah I know
that Stallone is hidden miss but I'm
surprised that he was like yeah let's
make this script I didn't even really
want to talk about this movie I don't
see it growing on me I don't recommend
it don't say I don't recommend if you
have to see the next Rambo movie you're
already seeing it and that's not you
yeah I don't recommend it snow or the
half-hour of cool action very end all
right guys what did you see last blood
you mad at us go ahead and talk about it
I don't care subscribe to the rejects
click that notification bell yeah we'll
catch you guys soon
thanks for being here